kind of wine welcome to see you're
playing giltch okay I'm to try the bank
owned and don't get it and okay I wanted
to play g6 okay maybe you can play it
with the whole tempo down I'm not
playing well but I'm also playing
somewhat unlucky it with with stuff like
age 6 okay okay it's a full tempo h6 is
a totally useless more may be in this
position it's not really hurting much
yeah it's not important to have this
move but that's um it also doesn't seem
to hurt much I can go before here or
what hmm hmm yeah being a tempo down
here is somewhat important I could have
taken and then whoops c8 what am I doing
here ah free should take a cold shower
or something before the next session to
get away me neither I'm seeing things
but I just see them after i move 96 is
complete nonsense i can just take si for
ya no no this is
filling and it's this is complete bogus
yeah I just just just in a terrible
position now completely your tech
it's really the worst if you see the
move right afterwards I mean clearly
indicating that somehow other I don't
know the field is off I mean you you see
it immediately but right after you put
it on the wall I don't know if I five
was any good but I didn't really pay any
attention I've too frustrated and how
would he go he's sexy if we're not doing
playing very clumsily here of course I
did not want to play f6 in this position
my opponent must think I'm drunk or
something oh it doesn't really take it
Wow and then this is actually not that
bad just my seating position yell
something that I keep doing those sir
wiki mouse lips
not really threatening anything here but
please that look somewhat active
and threatening absolutely nothing he
can probably even go see five nope
didn't do it okay still I don't have
something radium e6 would be nice for
Bishop deform but would be very
cooperative cooperative aside and it
would in English yeah would have helped
so I can actually take it here or not
you can check me on on the aid it's okay
check
here's some somewhat active after that
I'm not so active to probably have to
cover now it's better here I Quincy six
or something it's probably probably good
cannot read I had bishop you form check
still have the move no it's actually
good I can swindle them that's awful
after this crappy game with the light
presented all those small slips h 6 + f6
and whatever yeah that's really terrible
okay and the worst is night before I
mean this is just just awful I take 66
seconds to go back and this is very
obvious and so I'd immediately
afterwards I mean it said it's a typical
motif those two hanging nights here
black is of course in great shape yeah
and after going back and basically lost
this is just a bad position he could
have taken on b7 which was this was even
stronger and I'm pretty much lost and
now here of course I'm a porn down for
nothing and two here wow this looks
terrible it was a mouse club maybe it
isn't all that bad at least I get some
some kind of murkiness into the position
but I'm bad
check right up to the very end when when
he blunders Shander into the check made
so yeah it's better to be lucky than
good it's definitely true okay thanks
for watching